let's go to the phone 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
why don't we try the 2 4 0 area code
that's a dicey one that can explode or
sometimes there's no one there at 2 4 0
feel like we're going around the world
sometimes sometimes like who is it from
2 4 0 that's with us that's you oh oh I
did it well my name is Adam can you hear
me I'm actually only a Bluetooth headset
I remember seeing something about you
saying that yeah bluetooth isn't good
it's it's the ugly twin to speakerphone
for radio calls but we'll do what we can
what's your question Adam okay you know
that's a bit of a long question so um
have there ever been any bills that can
regulate the prices of more or any bills
proposed that could regulate the prices
of more common goods such as food and
things like that I understand that you
know advocates of a free market will
probably lose their heads over something
like that but given that there are you
know detractors to the whole $15 minimum
wage and the whole wage increase
activism going on when the next best
step be to try to regulate prices at the
very least the most common good so that
you know those that don't make enough
can't afford it well I mean listen the
way that a lot of that stuff is
regulated indirectly so like farm bills
can impact the price of some of our food
we have corn subsidies heavy heavy corn
subsidies which make products that
contain corn cheaper although those are
significantly those are products that
aren't food products that aren't
particularly healthy for us so I think I
understand what you're saying but we
already don't really have a free market
when it comes to food in the same way
that we don't have a free market when it
comes to energy because we subsidize oil
and gas so I think that it's dangerous
territory when you get into that and it
sounds like chaos in the background
there so I appreciate the call I'm gonna
let you go Adam point taken and and sort
of well-made but it seems like you might
have
a lot that you're juggling there so I'm
gonna let you let you get back to it
I think someone's writhing and paint
over this it's an election campaign yeah
I hope that that audio is never
subpoenaed as evidence in some kind of
violent violent crime